for the past 9 Minutes the space shuttle
has been powering its way through the
atmosphere propelled forward by two
massive solid rocket boosters completing
their duties 2 minutes into the flight
they are now falling back to Earth where
they will be refurbished and reused the
final push comes from the Orbiter three
main engines being fed liquid oxygen and
liquid hydrogen from the Colossal orange
external tank at an astonishing rate
having drained the 700 tons of fuel and
oxidizer from its tanks the time has
come to shut down the powerful main
engines and jettison the external tank
the astronauts inside the Orbiter will
find themselves transitioning from an
exhilarating thundering journey to a
Serene silent Cru becoming weightless
the moment the engines power down the
light of The Shining Blue Earth Below
them flood Through the Windows of the
crew cabin the journey to orbit has
ended but their mission has just begun
the space shuttle was was not just a
rocket it was a mobile laboratory a home
in space and it came with all the tools
the astronauts needed to not just
survive but to complete complicated
tasks in space a sanctuary amidst the
unforgiving expanse of space the Orbiter
provided a secure Haven sustaining a
breathable atmosphere facilitating
precise Maneuvers a payload Bay capable
of carrying massive spacecraft like the
hobble Space Telescope and the Machinery
needed to repair them when needed the
this is the insane engineering of the
Space Shuttle
Orbiter the astronaut's jobs begin the
moment they reach orbit the Orbiter has
released the external tank and it's
beginning its Journey back through the
atmosphere where it will disintegrate
this is the last view anyone will have
of the external tank intact and it was
vital that photos of it were taken to
check for any issues that could have
occurred on a scent to do this the
commander of the Orbiter needs to pitch
the shuttle onto its back using its
maneuvering system scattered all over
the Orbiter are smaller rocket nozzles
part of the reaction control system this
removable module in the nose of the
aircraft was the forward reaction
control system inside there are two
spherical tanks an oxidizer tank filled
with nitrogen tetroxide and a fuel tank
filled with monometal hydrazine this
fuel oxidizer comp comination is unique
it doesn't need an ignition Source it's
hypergolic meaning they spontaneously
ignite upon contact with each other but
both substances were extremely toxic
producing ominous orange clouds of toxic
gas breathing this in would cause your
lungs to rapidly fill with fluid and
once in your bloodstream it interferes
with the blood's ability to carry oxygen
anyone working with these propellants
had to wear pressurized breathing suits
to prevent any chance of contact
the astronauts also had exclusion zones
around these nozzles on spacewalks to
prevent any danger of the chemicals
coming back aboard it's an undesirable
fuel to work with in many ways but its
advantages were why it was used these
hypergolic fuels were extremely reliable
igniting on contact with each other
removed any need for complicated
ignition systems that could fail they
could be stored for longer periods than
cryogenic fuels that would have to be
continually vented as temperatures
throws which makes cryogenic fuels
unsuitable for longer missions like the
space shuttle with the longest space
shuttle mission lasting 18 days this was
critical the propellants could also be
quickly mixed in precise volumes to
provide precise and instantaneous thrust
control this was important when
maneuvering in close proximity to
another spacecraft the propellants are
fed into the combustion chamber through
pressurization of the tanks with high
press helium held in spherical Kevlar
composite tanks with titanium inner
liners an extremely lightweight tank
just 10 kg in weight but nearly a half
meter in diameter spherical tanks are
the most weight efficient form of
pressure vessel with the highest volume
to weight ratio ideally all Rockets
could use spherical tanks But ultimately
diameters increase too much as volume
requirements rise and it's preferable to
minimize the cross-sectional area of the
rocket to reduce drag there is no turbo
pump needed here the back pressure from
The High Press helium provides enough
flow rate for the purposes of these low
power Rocket Motors in the forward
reaction control system pod there are 12
main thrusters and there are 12 in each
of the left and right rear pods too for
a total of 38 main thrusters each
capable of providing
3,870 Newtons of thrust with a specific
impulse of 289 seconds sometimes even
finer control was needed for delicate
docking procedures and for this the
Orbiter had six smaller verer thrusters
capable of producing as little as 111
Newtons the same amount of force you
would need to lift an 11 kg weight here
on Earth with a total of 44 reaction
control thrusters scattered around the
Orbiter the astronauts needed a way to
control them the controls were located
at the commander seat on the left side
of the cockpit and here on the left side
of the AFT Flight Deck the rear position
was added to allow the commander to look
out this rear window while maneuvering
for rendevu with other spacecraft or
releasing payloads each station had a
square knob controller used for
translational movements in and out side
to side and up and down and a more
traditional flight stick which was used
to control attitude pitch roll and yaw
there was also a flight computer where
desired altitude and velocity changes
could be entered with a keypad of course
this was all fly by by wire the
Commander's inputs were all fed into a
computer which interpreted the commands
and decided the best course of action
there was only one notable exception for
this flyby wire system I mean there is
nothing mechanically linked to any of
the control surfaces or anything
everything is goes through the computer
Everything You Touch goes through the
computer and the computer generates
everything we are concerned about things
called single event upset you've
probably heard of this before where a
cosmic ray comes in and upsets the
computers and you can recover from
anything but because there was no way to
raise the landing gear we were concerned
a single event upset if there was an
automatic computer way to lower the
wheels that you could get your wheels
lowered on orbit and not be able to come
home so we always made that made that
mechanical and so once we got down to
under 300t 200 ft that was the Pilot's
main job was to lower the wheels
manually putting them back in place
required ground crew to push them back
in so because ionizing radiation in
space could potentially trigger the
computers to lower the landing gear and
with no way of raising them back up they
were lowered manually the landing gears
were held in place by a hooked lock that
was released after the pilot flipped the
protective covers on these two buttons
an arming button and a button labeled DN
for down when this happened a hydraulic
actuator released the hook holding the
landing gears in place and allowed them
to lower the first day of the mission is
now starting the astronauts begin their
tasks the pilot and Commander seated in
the left and right seats in front of the
instrument panel are busy working
towards the First rendevu with Intel sat
through the forward Windows the
astronauts can glimpse a distant bright
dot the satellite they are maneuvering
towards these weren't the only windows
on board there were additional overhead
Windows along with rear windows looking
into the payload Bay which for now
remains closed these windows were key to
the reusability of the shuttle the
windows had to be durable enough to
survive space debris impacts and capable
of resisting the temperatures of
re-entry the space shuttle's window
structure had multiple layers of glass
each tailored to withstand different
conditions the pressure Paine was
engineered to endure the cabin pressure
in space it was made from 15.7 mm thick
Aluma silicate glass that was tempered
to be mechanically strong on the outer
edge of this pane a red film was added
to reflect back the heat into the
vehicle so it wasn't lost to space while
still letting visible light through the
outermost pain or the thermal pain was
also 15.7 mm thick and capable of
resisting temperatures of up to 482 de C
there was also a large space between
these two panes which minimized heat
transfer between the outer shell and the
inner crew cabin on one Discovery
mission one of these windows was struck
by space debris leaving a small crater
in the window but it did not break if it
had the astronauts inside were in no
danger as there was also a center
redundant pain serving as a fail safe
for both the thermal and pressure pains
it was 33 mm thick and made out of fused
silica glass the same material that
laboratory crucibles and beakers are
made out of the rear windows looking
into the payload Bay did not have the
outer thermal pain since they would not
be exposed to the extreme superhe plasma
during re-entry there were no windows in
the mid deck below the crew deck the mid
deck is where many of the science
experiments in orbit were performed and
this is where the astronauts slept in
Ace there were stations where the
astronauts could strap themselves to the
walls in the weightless environment but
not everyone chose to use them the
commander and pilot generally slept up
on the flight deck they would just
Loosely strap themselves in their you
know commander and pilot seats uh that
was that was a good way and you want to
be kind of strapped in there were some
astronauts like story Musgrave that like
to free float around in space but he
would bump into people and I heard that
it was quite annoying sometimes but the
rest of us you have a a cloth sleeping
bag that's made out of you know just
light material like this where you you
velcro it to a bulkhead or the ceiling
and you just zip yourself up in it the
time has now come to open the payload
doors the doors needed to be opened
shortly after reaching orbit as one of
the space shuttles vital life support
systems require them to be open the
temperature control system two radiator
panels are attached to each of the
forward payload bay doors Freon fill
tubes snake around these panels where
they radiate heat absorbed from a heat
exchanger located inside the Orbiter
into space the payload doors themselves
are made from a graphite epoxy composite
material which reduced the weight of the
doors by 48 kg over a comparable
aluminium design at the time this was
the largest Aerospace composite
structure ever made covering the payload
Bay which was 18.3 M long and 4.6 M wide
the largest and heaviest payload it ever
carried was on SDs 93 with the Chandra
x-ray Observatory coming in at 22.7 tons
maxing out the shuttle's capacity this
Mission came worryingly close to
disaster during each refurbishment of
the shuttle's main engines they were
inspected with ultrasound to find signs
of damage in some cases damage may be
detected in one of the liquid oxygen
posts that delivered liquid oxygen to
the combustion chamber and instead of
replacing the entire expensive and
difficult to manufacture injection
assembly the post was simply deactivated
with a gold pin that plugged the channel
during the pre-launch startup sequence
of the main engines on SDs 93 one of
these gold pins was ejected out and
struck the hydrogen coolant channels in
the nozzle resulting in a hydrogen leak
that you can actually see here in images
of the launch the engine detected a
decrease in combustion chamber pressure
and opened the oxidizer valve to
increase thrust the engine had no way of
knowing the issue was a hydrogen leak It
could only detect the drop in combustion
chamber pressure and respond by making
the combustion less fuel Rich which
increases thrust and temperature this
incident resulted in a maintenance
policy switch that meant damaged oxygen
posts had to be replaced and not simply
plugged thankfully the engine survived
and the mission was successfully
completed despite the main engines
shutting down prematurely as a result of
the oxygen depletion sensors being
triggered so the Orbiter was 4.6 m/s off
its Target orbital velocity thankfully
the Orbiter had an orbital maneuvering
system that could bring it up to its
desired velocity these large rocket Noz
musles were not part of the reaction
control system and were capable of
providing 305 m/s of additional velocity
powered by the same hypergolic Fuel and
oxidizer as the RCs system from tanks
hidden within the ohms pods capable of
holding 4 tons of fuel and 6.7 tons of
oxidizer when performing large orbital
changes like this it was important for
the space shuttle to know precisely
where it was and to do this it could
open these doors on the left side of the
Orbiter nose revealing the stair tracker
Optics these stair trackers analyzed
known positions of the stairs in the sky
to determine exactly where the Orbiter
was allowing it to precisely navigate in
orbit once the space shuttle has arrived
at its Target orbit the real work can
begin on Bruce's Mission STS 49 the
first task was to rendevu with that
stranded communication satellite
carefully maneuvering the orbit closer
to the satellite as the satellites
operators attempted to stabilize its
spin as they approached two astronauts
Pierre 2 and Richard hee dawned their
Eva suits in the mid deck and prepared
to enter the airlock the airock for this
mission was located inside the crew
cabin of the mid deck but it could be
configured to be outside in the payload
area during the construction of the
International Space Station a special
docking system was also installed which
was required to allow the space shuttle
to dock to both Russian and American
spacecraft it was called the androgenous
peripheral attached system the
androgynous name comes from the fact
that both the Target and the receiving
end look identical with no male or
female parts with the goal of this being
a universal docking system allowing any
two spacecraft to dock together as Gard
intended each side had a ring with three
petals equally distributed one side
extended its mating ring for a soft
capture where the three Petals of each
side come together and connect with
these latches at this point the soft
capture ring is retracted and 12 latches
engaged to form an airtight connection
between the two spacecraft this system
was used extensively during the
construction of the International Space
Station which the space shuttle had an
instrumental role in transporting and
assembling in space including the very
first modules to be connected in 1998 on
SDs 88 when the Orbiter doed with the
Russian Zaria module using the docking
ring and proceeded to connect the unity
module on STS 49 Bruce's Mission the
stranded satellite was never intended to
be docked with and had no docking points
and thus to capture the stranded
satellite the astronauts needed to
perform an Eva and manually grab the
satellite using a capture bear
specifically designed for this Mission
but not everything went to plan so we
made several attempts to grab this
satellite with the capture bar but every
time Pierre touched the bottom of the
satellite with the capture bar it
bounced off out of control fortunately
the engineers that owned Intel sat they
could send commands back up to it
restabilize it so we could maneuver back
closer to it and try again so we tried
three or four times the first day to
grab it every time it bounced off second
day we tried again every time it bounced
off so at that point we were kind of at
a loss we didn't know what we were going
to do and of course all this time I'm
operating the arm I'm chasing the
satellite with Pierre on the end of it
and so it was a it was a very demanding
part of the flight so after two days of
trying the ground said okay we're going
to take the third day off and then we're
go back out and try on the fourth day to
do it again well of course we felt like
the mission was lost so you know we the
ground told us go ahead get a good
night's sleep we'll call you in the
morning so we got to thinking a matter
fact I saw that I could hear that Dan
and Chile were talking up on the flight
deck we were supposed to be asleep so I
floated up to the Flight Deck with them
and they were talking about how Endeavor
was so maneuverable and was so efficient
on its fuel burn that they thought we
could get close enough to the satellite
to where Rick and Pierre could just grab
it with their gloved hands and we saw it
at one point when Pierre got the capture
bar one side of the capture bar fired
and it almost immediately stop the
rotation so we knew that it was going to
be easy to stop the rotation if Rick and
Pierre could just grab the the bottom of
the satellite the problem was is now
what do you do if you do grab the
satellite you've got two guys out there
holding a 9,000lb satellite with no way
to get it back on the rocket motor that
we took up to strap to it to send it
back up to the proper orbit well I
scratched my head while I was up there
and I knew that uh because after we
finished this satellite business
two other astronauts Tom Acres and Kathy
Thornton they were going to go out and
do some practice of assembly of the
space station you know we hadn't built
the Space Station at that point and they
were going to be out trying to do some
methods for that well in order to
accommodate all the differ sized
astronauts the Eva suits or the space
walking suits they're made out of
different components different length
arms differ Siz torsos uh those sorts of
things and Rick hee is this big Kathy
Thorton was this tall and then Tom and
uh Pierre are about my size so in order
to accommodate four astronauts on two
different space walks of those different
sizes we for the first time ever had
three full Eva suit the components of
three full Eva suits on board so I got
to think and I said well we have three
suits on board why don't we send three
space Walkers out you know we've got we
can have two people grab it and then one
person put the capture bar on because
the capture bar had to be attached to
the satellite because that was what was
going to attach it to the rocket motor
that we brought
up however this plan had one problem the
airlock was only designed for two people
the airlock consisted of two airtight
doors once inside with the door sealed
the astronauts could depressurize the
inside by venting the air to space this
could only be done from inside the hatch
but repressurization could be done from
outside and inside for obvious safety
reasons this process proc took about 30
minutes and while it happened the
astronauts were connected to life
support em biblical so that they didn't
have to waste their internal supplies
during the waight this was the first
problem there were only two life support
em biblical available it was also going
to be a tight squeeze for three
astronauts with full Eva gear on as the
cylindrical airlock inside the mid deck
was just 160 cm in diameter and 210 CM
High the third astronaut was going to
need to make some sacrifices so unlike
normally where you just have two
astronauts you put him in the air lock
you close the door with Tom he had to go
on all of his internal controls and we
float him in the air lock upside down so
now you've got Rick and Pierre right
side up and Tom Acres head down in the
airlock and he's on his internal systems
now where Rick and Pierre are still
attached to the umbilicals inside close
the airlock Evac at it and then all
three of them floated out and here the
three astronauts got to work with Bruce
on the remote manipulator arm controls
inside the Orbiter and he was chosen for
a very specific reason he was a Coast
Guard helicopter pilot and the reason
you know Dan wanted to have a Coast
Guard helicopter pilot on the arm and
the reason for that is is that operating
the arm the controls that you use are
you vaguely similar to operating a
helicopter because in a helicopter you
know you have to fly with both hands and
both feet well when you're operating the
arm you've got two controllers you've
got a rotational hand controller and a
translational hand controller so the
translational hand controller youve you
know you move up down sideways in and
out rotational hand controller controls
the attitude of the arm so it's very
much like flying a helicopter and you
can't be thinking about it when you're
in a very you know tight situation
you've got to be the arm the canadarm
named after its country of origin was a
multi-functional tool used for many
tasks aboard the shuttle a simple
articulated arm may not seem overly
impressive but the unique physics of a
weightless environment and the desire to
minimize the launch weight of the Space
Shuttle made for a very interesting
engineering challenge the entire 15 M
long arm weighs just 430 kg and despite
being able to move 30 tons in orbit it
couldn't even hold up its own weight on
Earth the booms were made from low
weight epoxy graphite composite with six
joints Two Joints at its shoulder for
yaw and Pitch one elbow pitch joint and
three joints at the wrist for yaw pitch
and roll for a total of six degrees of
freedom of movement exactly like your
own arm however your elbow is only
capable of about 140° of pitch before
your bicep gets in the way the Canada
arms elbow joint rotational access is
offset by 0 .15 M to allow up to 160° of
rotation because the arm is working in a
weightless environment the motors don't
need to be able to apply that much
torque each motor could only produce 0.7
n m of torque with no friction in space
a small force can move any Mass it just
depends how long you want it to take in
the same way ion thrusters with thrusts
of just 25 millons could theoretically
get a spacecraft up to light speed if it
had enough propellant however the
dangers of inertia are still real if a
satellite was moving quickly relative to
the arm he could easily bend and break
the arm so delicate movement is the name
of the game and the motor can work in
Reverse to assist each joint brake
system the loaded arm speed had a
maximum speed of just 6 cm/ second the
arm had a unique end fixture designed to
Grapple onto attachment points on
satellites however because the Intel set
was never intended to be Rend vued with
it didn't have any grapple points
installed so the capture barar had an
attachment point for the second stage
rocket and had a grapple Point allowing
the Canada arm to grab hold of it once
it was securely attached the grapple
point is a simple metallic pin with
three loes at its base this is all the
arm needed to firmly grab onto the Intel
sat the end Defector of the Canada arm
used a naturally self-centered ing wire
grapple system to hold on to this pin
three wires each anchored at two points
one point is stationary while the
secondary Anchor Point is attached to a
rotating ring once Bruce had maneuvered
the arm over the grapple Rod using the
camera feed this rotating ring would
turn and ens snare the pin pulling it to
the center the pin is then pulled
inwards until the three loes at its base
lock into corresponding cutouts on the
outside of the grapple ring a simple but
effective mechanism with the satellite
now secure the three astronauts could
get to work attaching the new second
stage to the capture bar which they did
successfully allowing the Intel sat to
raise itself to geostationary orbit
where it operated for 21 years STS 49
had another mission to complete a test
run of space shuttle building techniques
but with their time in orbit running out
that mission lost a day life support
systems on board were supplied with
enough gases for the planned duration of
the mission spherical tanks in the mid
fuse LOD contained highpressure oxygen
and nitrogen with three nitrogen tanks
and one oxygen used to create a
breathable atmosphere of 80% nitrogen
and 20% oxygen of course carbon dioxide
needed to be scrubbed from the air and
this was done by passing the cabin air
through lithium hydroxide canisters
located underneath the mid deck these
solid canisters would react with the CO2
to remove it from the atmosphere spere
and create water in the process this was
not a renewable solution so every 12
hours the crew would access and replace
these canisters through the hatch on the
mid deck Bay there were also oxygen and
hydrogen tanks used for the space
shuttle power system a fuel cell that
reacted the hydrogen and oxygen to
produce water and electricity these
powered everything on board and produced
water in the process but this water
carried some extra hydrogen gas so
before the water could be used it had to
go through a process of degassing which
separates the hydrogen and dumps it
overboard it was now time to prepare for
re-entry and the first step was closing
those payload doors but on STDs 49
another problem was encountered the
payload doors would not latch due to
Thermal warping of the Doris requiring
some creative problem solving there's
always two astronauts trained to do Evas
and and I was trained to do an Eva on my
first flight and that's for a
contingency if for example the payload
bay doors wouldn't close or latch all
the way when you're on orbit we have
special tools where we could winch them
closed and and latch them all together
and matter of fact on STS
49 after we had trouble getting the the
satellite to launch because of a
different switch configuration we got up
there and the payload bay doors wouldn't
close all the way and so we thought oh
man do we need to go back out and do
that so your first attempt to fix
something like that is the thermal loads
on the space SP shuttle as you can
imagine you know you're 200° in The
Sunny Side and 200° below zero on the on
the dark side so a lot of times the
you'll get a little bit of a oil canning
effect or a little twisting of the
fuselage just because of the thermal
effects and that's what we did we went
ahead into what we call the barbecue
mode and we started so we went ahead and
orbited the Earth in the barbecue mode
to try to equalize the temperatures on
the shuttle when we couldn't get the
payload bay doors to close all the way
and when you say barbecue mode do you
mean like like a spit roast it's like
rotating yes yeah we and I it's not that
fast but you do that to where you try to
equally heat while you're going you know
through the Sun and through the dark and
I I think it was just one orbit we had
to do and we tried to close the doors
again and they latched with the door
successfully closed the space shuttle
could begin its preparations to reenter
the Earth's atmosphere firing the ohms
engines once more to slow down the
orbital velocity and slowly bring it
back into Earth's atmosphere as at the
moment of re-entry the space shuttle
will be traveling between 7 and 8 km/s
entering the thin upper atmosphere at 30
times the speed of sound a speed so
great that it begins to rip air
molecules apart creating a glowing cloud
of charge plasma around the lower
surface of the Orbiter with Peak
temperatures reaching
1,650 de C to not only withstand this
immense heat but to transition to a
glider capable of landing on a Runway
way required some incredible Innovative
engineering combining Aerospace and
Aviation Technologies like never before
a true space
plane episode three of the insane
engineering of the Space Shuttle
detailing the engineering of re-entry
and Landing will be uploaded in the
coming weeks as we take a short break to
celebrate the holidays with our friends
and family you are likely doing the same
and perhaps you're looking for a
thoughtful gift for the enthusiastic
Learners in your life or perhaps you
want to set set some New Year's goals
and learn some valuable skills brilliant
can help you with both brilliant makes
Learning Easy with fun interactive
courses that really succeed in getting
you that dopamine Rush as they test your
knowledge along the way they have a
fantastic mobile app so you can learn on
the goto I just completed the course
teaching how large language models like
Chachi BT work with the prevalence of
that technology ever growing learning
about how it works is incredibly
valuable or perhaps you want to get
ahead in University and learn some
valuable engineering skills like how to
use vectors to describe Motion in both
engineering and computer science
brilliant has thousands of other lessons
too AI data science neural networks and
even our very own partnered real
engineering course you can get access to
that course right now and all of
brilliant's other curated interactive
courses by going to brilliant.org slre
engineering or by clicking the link in
the description you can get started for
free for 30 days and the first 500
people to do so will get 20% off
brilliant's annual premium
subscription